why don't we go next to Alex from San
Diego Alex you're on the air
wow hello I didn't actually expect okay
we've chosen
um
so I have a quick I have a question for
you yeah I've long thought that the most
important issue in politics today is the
impact that money has on politics and
then if you solve that a lot of the
other issues would naturally solve
themselves over time as People's Natural
Instincts are very reasonable
in general do you do you agree that this
is the most important issue or do you
see something else is the most important
issue today I believe that there is a
sort of triumvirate or a uh three-headed
monster of sorts that are really the
three most important uh issues
systemically and you hit on one of them
money in politics is one aspect of this
uh climate change is a sort of systemic
and structural issue where if Cities end
up underwater
it's not going to really matter what our
opinion about abortion is so it's sort
of like whatever issue you care about if
we don't deal with climate change we're
not going to be able to to get that
fixed and then thirdly would be uh how
are elections are are run meaning that
they're mostly first past the post and
and for the presidency it's an electoral
college system so all those three issues
together if we could fix campaign
Finance money in politics if we could
get to some kind of transferable vote
and get rid of the Electoral College and
then if we could deal with climate
change then we would sort of be set up
to start dealing with like okay I care
about education here's how I'll be an
activist on education you might care
about you know trans rights here's how
you can get involved in that I I think
that you are right in identifying one of
the three major issues
see that that's kind of my point though
I feel like a lot of those other issues
can in many ways be reduced down to the
money and politics issue like climate
change for example if money and Paul if
money if there was some way to resolve
campaign Finance so then over time
candidates would begin to more
accurately represent the will of the
people hopefully or ideally and most
people want to do something about
climate change yeah I don't disagree in
in that you're saying that over the long
term that we might get to some kind of
equilibrium but it would be a long time
because even if you quote dealt with
money in politics
fossil fuels are still advantaged in a
number of different ways including by
the sheer Market power that they have in
ways that are not directly connected to
money in politics so I'm with you about
the long term I think if we wanted to
more quickly do something about it I
would still put these three issues sort
of as the the three-headed monster that
needs to be dealt with
I see very thank you for that um I have
one other very minor thing if you don't
try it
um
um this the other thing is I've I've had
this idea and I don't know if anyone
else has talked about it I've never
heard it talked about but
um it's related to like how to address
worker executive pay disparity why
in addition to also being able to
increase taxes on
um very wealthy people on you know and
wealth in general
um and I realize this idea may not may
be unpassable but nonetheless I want to
know what you think of it sure why not
tie the tax rate for corporations to the
up to the difference between like the
highest paid Executives and the median
pay of the company such that the bigger
that disparity the more the company pays
in some additional tax and if they want
to reduce that tax they have to improve
average worker pay it's a super
interesting idea and so to give an
example the way it might work would be
uh if you um if the CEO earns a hundred
times more than the lowest paid person
you pay a twelve percent corporate tax
rate but if the CEO earns a thousand
times that of the lowest paid person
your tax rate goes up to 40 something
like that right I mean not those numbers
but that's the idea yeah I think it's
super interesting I think there's a
couple problems one is I don't know how
something like that even comes close to
passing but let's let's ignore that
right because we're talking about
whether it's a good idea I think you
still because the corporate tax rate
first of all applies only to certain
businesses any self-proprietorship LLC S
corporation those are passed through so
the corporate tax rate doesn't even make
a difference to them unless you deal
with that and the fact that you can
still deduct and loophole your way down
to zero tax liability you would need to
still combine it with an alternative
minimum tax for corporations you'd have
to do a bunch of other stuff it's
interesting practically speaking I don't
see any way that it would pass in the
next 20 years but I think it's a really
interesting idea
okay thank you for that dude that's all
I have keep up all right good work thank
you very much uh guys the the cut this
is week three of really strong phone
calls really really strong phone calls
not going to lie I'm uh we we've really
kind of hit a uh hit our stride I guess
I would say let's go to Chandler from
Indianapolis Chandler from Indianapolis
you're on there
uh hello can you hear me yes I can
hey David uh first time calling long
time listener hate to be that cliche
thank you but um
yeah so I just have a question about
covet in general so
um I live in Indianapolis and um
just recently The Mask mandate was
lifted for the city uh City County
Council lifted it on
uh Monday night and
something that really concerns me is
that uh
the percentage of the people who live in
the city
um who have gotten the vaccine at least
like one shot
there's only like I think I think it's
like 36 percentage uh you know less than
40 percent yikes
um
I'm not really sure what you would think
for or what what let me let me just
rephrase this so
what would you think would be a
reasonable percentage for a mask mandate
to be lifted for a city
um you know like the size of
Indianapolis I don't know how it is with
Boston or how it is up there
yeah I don't you know that I'm not an
epidemiologist or an immunologist so so
basically I'm going by what I've read
those experts say but it seems quite
reasonable to me that as you approach 50
um uh immunized that uh certainly masks
can start coming off and we're seeing
masks come off in most places and things
seem to be more or less going okay among
the vaccinated the unvaccinated are
seeing increased hospitalizations in
some places like in Tennessee but uh
yeah I mean I think at 50 you can start
to to really do a lot of things
oh yeah for sure I I would definitely
agree and honestly at this point of the
pandemic I would believe that
you know some things are kind of common
sense like if you're gonna go to Walmart
I would probably wear a mask
if um you were to go out to a park you
know don't wear a mask unless there's
like a crowd for whatever reason yeah so
right I think that Common Sense would
definitely be
uh kind of what we all need to be uh
listening for yeah and remember that the
CDC has said that once you are
vaccinated essentially every activity is
low risk without a mask but certainly if
there's a situation in which you still
would be more comfortable with a mask I
say wear it why not
yeah oh yeah for sure
um
yeah and um let me see
well that's all great I'm gonna let you
go because we have so many people but
that's a great question and I'm
hopefully things will continue to
improve in Indianapolis
I appreciate you uh taking the call uh
all right what are you doing man very
good thank you so much let's take a
really quick break if you're holding
don't hang up because we are taking more
calls momentarily stay with us
I've often had trouble falling asleep
when I'm staring at my computer or phone
screen late into the night and that's
partially because blue light from
screens suppresses the sleep hormone
melatonin and blue light can generally
cause things like eye strain or even
headaches but it has not been an issue
for me since I was sent a pair of blue
blocks glasses which block out blue
light unlike all of the low quality
mass-produced blue light glasses out
there blue blocks are actually
evidence-backed made under Optics
laboratory conditions these are the blue
light glasses you can trust and they
have something for everybody lenses for
daytime lenses you wear before bed they
have a prescription version
non-prescription readers over 40
different frames to choose from these
are the ones I picked out I never have
problems with it anymore it's great go
to blueblocks.com Pacman or click the
link below and you'll get 20 off when
you use the coupon code pacman20 and
there's free shipping worldwide on
orders over a hundred and fifteen
dollars